views of fogo island off Canada's
Atlantic coast and the Chinese capital
Beijing on an unusually clear day or the
capital of Allahabad in India where the
Hindu festival Camilla was celebrated
this year there a small taste of the
pictures taken by Dutch photographer
even ban on his travels he covered 52
cities in 52 weeks my life is a non-stop
traveling life so I live 365 days a year
in hotels out of suitcases this show is
a kind of diary of the last year of
places we've been to people we've met
and things we've seen the barter Museum
and half for Germany is presenting the
first solo exhibition of the
photographers work it encompasses 60
images showing how people live all over
the world
even bond gives a glimpse of many
different habitats for the 38 year old
the project marks a return to his
artistic roots they came from a
background doing a documentary
photography but there was always
interested in space and people and
they're the subjects of my pictures
usually and sort of the architecture
happens sort of in a way anyway in the
background it's the place what sort of
what brings people together so for me
people are in a very important part of
telling these stories and every picture
tells one like this photo taken in the
Nigerian city of Lagos it shows a
floating school by the architect con la
adeyemi it's a pilot project designed to
promote alternative living spaces in a
region prone to flooding
Plus Monsieur taters I really like the
fact that none of the pictures look
contrived more as if they were taken by
chance despite that they're very precise
very expressive he always incorporates
people into his pictures and in doing so
they're very vivid and very personal you
can see how he felt about each different
place it's nice how the emphasis isn't
just on the architecture but also on the
people within the architecture which
isn't often the case with architectural
photography I like that because it's a
different approach Yvonne Vaughn has
also made a name for himself in recent
years as an architectural photographer
in May he shot the new hall at the messe
Basel exhibition centre by the swiss
firm l sog and Dumervil
he's also worked for British Iraqi
architect zaha hadid photographing the
library in Vienna that she designed an
art museum in Michigan and a cultural
center in Baku the capital of Azerbaijan
they're all on show in the current
exhibition yesh Takaful even bonding day
yahan bond strength is that he
completely dissolves the concept of
architectural photography that means he
doesn't concentrate on iconic buildings
but he focuses on how we human shape
living spaces daba death master school I
think that's what's special about him
that he operates with an incredible love
of people places back from kite glide
attention to detail combined with a
friendly distance and a critical eye and
thoughts are ending AG yet even bond is
a big fan of aerial shots which allow
him to get a view of the bigger picture
like these images of the grounds of the
vitra Museum in viola mine
in October 2012 following Hurricane
sandy the lights went out in manhattan
and New York this photo was taken from a
helicopter under difficult conditions in
New York magazine ran it as its cover to
get that kind of bird's eye perspective
it like it shows to me also where
project is for me it's very important
always to find places which are very
specific for a specific region for
specific architect for specific
circumstances and so in all these places
are very much linked yet to specific
context and setting and that's important
for me to photograph the exhibition in
the marta museum and half odd runs until
februari 16th meanwhile Yvonne bond
continues his travels a new project
takes him to Iraq in a few weeks another
destination to be laid bare by his
unique scrutiny